i
[Música]
médicos rusos cambiaron de opinión y
autorizaron el traslado de alexéi
navalni hacia alemania para que reciba
tratamiento
el líder opositor o ruso se encuentra en
coma y aunque las autoridades lo niegan
se habla de un posible envenenamiento
en las últimas semanas los contagios por
coronavirus en perú se han incrementado
en 100.000 positivos el peor registro
desde que la enfermedad llegó al país
una situación que ha obligado al
gobierno a prohibir todas las reuniones
familiares y restringir las salidas de
los menores para tratar de detener la
pantalla
los dos gobiernos rivales de libia
anunciaron un alto el fuego inmediato un
gesto que da esperanza a una posible paz
estable luego de seis años de guerra
civil en el país la onu recibió con
satisfacción el avance del presidente
egipcio celebró este paso hacia la
estabilidad en la región
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france24 cerro blanco un
gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo en rusia donde las
autoridades médicas cambiaron de opinión
y dieron luz verde para que el opositor
alexéi navalni víctima de un presunto
envenenamiento se ha trasladado a
alemania según la agencia de noticias
reuters en abanilla salió del hospital
en siberia donde se encontraba
los médicos negaron que naval y tuviera
rastros de veneno en su sangre después
de que esté enferma la repentinamente
mientras se encontraba a bordo de un
avión tanto su familia como sus
seguidores aseguran que el líder
opositor fue víctima de un
envenenamiento con uno con un té que
consumió durante el traslado aéreo
actualmente se encuentra en estado de
coma para analizar un poco de lo que
ocurre con un aval ni quiero saludar en
este momento a vladimir rubinsky
profesor de ciencia política y
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad ese sí profesor buenas
noches gracias por estar con nosotros en
france 24 no es la primera vez que
llegan denuncias de envenenamientos a
opositores en la rusia
y me puteen recordemos por ejemplo el
caso del ex oficial sg skripal en reino
unido- y también el de su hija el
kremlin siempre ha negado toda
implicación en el caso de naval y los
medios dicen que no hay rastro de veneno
en la sangre y también lo dicen los
médicos y la oposición dice que los
médicos esperan un tiempo suficiente
para que los rastros ya no pudieran ser
encontrados que cree usted que ocurrió
con el opositor naval
buenas noches muchas gracias por esta
invitación yo creo que es bastante
difícil en este movimiento tener una
versión clara sobre qué es lo que
realmente pasó con elección naval lo que
se sabe muy bien que no vale cosas de
muy buena salud practica deporte no
consuma alcohol y prácticamente hasta el
momento cuando aparecen los primeros
síntomas de que pasó algo al bordo de un
avión que está ya en pleno vuelo él
prácticamente se sentía perfectamente o
sea no web absolutamente nada de que
pudo indicar que algo pudo pasar o que
tiene problemas con su salud y por esta
razón hay mucha sospecha y las
circunstancias y precisamente el tiempo
en que ocurre esto es crucial para poder
realmente decir que algo no está bien
con esta situación
ahora podemos hablar de una estrategia
para sacar de la escena política a quien
era considerado el principal crítico del
kremlin que pasará ahora sin la
presencia de naval ni en el país en
rusia
si expresamente de lo que quiero hablar
porque hay elecciones regionales en
rusia en septiembre y natalia
precisamente estaba en esta ciudad
decidir entonces para apoyar a unos de
los candidatos a algunos activistas que
querían realmente dar una lucha para que
el partido del gobierno la rusia unida
no queda compuestos de poder hacia
entonces ex sin avales sería muy muy
difícil para la posición obtener
cualquier puesto en estos en estas
elecciones que quieran merecer y es
cualquier causa sería de la de la
situación en que se encuentran la habana
está muy claro que no va a poder volver
a la vida política rusa durante muchos
meses posiblemente profesor o blame y
robbins y gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en france 24 que
tengo usted una muy buena noche la líder
de la oposición velo rusa svetlana
deyanov acá ya que se encuentra
refugiada en lituania aseguró que no se
postularía a unas nuevas elecciones si
es que se repite en estos comicios
hice un llamado a que continúen las
movilizaciones en contra de alexander
lukashenko que ganó según dicen sus
detractores de manera fraudulenta
cientos de personas afirma formaron una
cadena humana en las calles demmings
como muestra de apoyo a las víctimas de
violencia en el país el presidente
alexander lukashenko acusó a eeuu de
estar detrás de estas manifestaciones
valentina torre sánchez nos cuenta más
es la primera vez que svetlana tica no
pesca ya habla con la prensa desde vilna
en la capital lituana desde que se
exilió el pasado 11 de agosto la líder
opositora bielorrusa pidió a los
ciudadanos que continúen en las calles
chichas violarlos belarús despertó
cientos de miles de personas salieron a
las calles de ciudades y pueblos para
decirle al gobierno ya basta
ujaldón basta de mentiras de intimidar a
la gente de violar las leyes y de
violencia la violencia debería parar los
presos políticos deberían ser liberados
y se deberían celebrar elecciones libres
honestas y transparentes price book in
exile ya la opositora respondió así a la
posibilidad de que rusia apoyó al
presidente alexander lukashenko con
soldados a adolfo llamó a todas las
naciones a respetar la soberanía de
nuestro país y a respetar la elección de
nuestro pueblo de choice of agua tipo
las declaraciones se presentan el mismo
día en que fueron interrogados dos
integrantes del recién creado consejo
coordinador opositor al que las
autoridades acusan de querer tomar el
poder nacional esto respondimos que el
consejo coordinador no tiene el objetivo
de intentar hacerse con el poder el
consejo coordinador es más un servicio
mediador para resolver un conflicto para
resolver una disputa pacíficamente hay
una situación compleja ahora entre las
autoridades del estado y el pueblo
bielorruso
por su parte el presidente alexander
lukashenko aseguró por primera vez que
eeuu se encuentra detrás de las
multitudinarias protestas ciudadanas y
acusó a la unión europea de seguirle el
juego debido a que el bloque decidió no
reconocer los resultados de las
elecciones del 9 de agosto doctor
preocupan los repuntes en los casos de
kobe 19 registrados en varios países de
europa francia registró más de 4500
casos en las últimas 24 horas o en un
momento en el que el país se debate
sobre la manera más segura de retomar
las clases en los colegios de españa por
su parte registró 3 mil 650 casos en un
día en este país donde ya se han
ordenado el cierre de discotecas y
lugares de ocio nocturno ahora la
ministra de igualdad
irene montero ha pedido el cierre de los
prostíbulos italia por su parte registró
ochocientos cuarenta y cinco casos la
cifra más alta desde que terminó el
confinamiento en el mes de mayo
pasamos ahora a noticias de américa
latina en las últimas dos semanas los
contagios o por coronavirus en perú se
han incrementado en ce mil positivos el
peor registro desde que la enfermedad
llegó al país en marzo una situación que
preocupa a las autoridades es el aumento
de contagios en los menores de edad y
también en los adolescentes que ha
obligado al gobierno a prohibir todas
las reuniones familiares y restringir
las salidas de los menores de edad para
tratar de detener esta pandemia
con síntomas leves o asintomáticos el
kobe 19 afecta también a los menores de
edad en perú desde finales de julio el
país ha registrado un importante
crecimiento en los contagios por corona
virus en personas de todas las edades
pero las autoridades alarman del
incremento del 70% en niños y
adolescentes llevándoles en poner nuevas
medidas de restricción que como llama
poderosamente la atención
es por ello
que no queremos prohibir la salida de
los niños sino queremos limitar la a los
iniciales 30 minutos la salida al parqué
es para los menores un alivio al
aislamiento pero también supone un mayor
riesgo para sus acompañantes los niños
son uno de los principales transmisores
silenciosos del virus a los adultos que
padecen las consecuencias más graves de
la enfermedad sin embargo el virus
afecta a los jóvenes con enfermedades
preexistentes o con cáncer según los
datos del ministerio de salud peruano
108 niños han fallecido ahora estamos en
otro momento en el cual los niños y si
están en un estado muy crítico pueden
fallecer no y eso lo son en todo el
mundo ya hemos llegado a los 23 mil
casos de niños contagiados en nuestro
país el retraso en la educación de los
menores es otra de las consecuencias de
la pandemia muchos no han podido acceder
a las clases online por falta de
recursos además la pobreza infantil
aumentaría en un 22% en latinoamérica
por el cob y 19 según proyecciones del
fondo de naciones unidas para la
infancia
en eeuu avanzan sin control los
incendios en el estado de california
cerca de 12.000 rayos han golpeado a
este estado generando más de 550 focos
de fuego en áreas secas el gobernador o
gavin newson confirmó que la ayuda ha
sido solicitada a canadá australia y
otros 10 estados de la unión americana
nos cuenta más matías arráez
once mil rayos en los últimos días dejan
a california ardiendo
el nuevo episodio de incendios que sufre
este estado ya ha dejado al menos 6
fallecidos y ha devastado más de 250.000
hectáreas más que el total de todos los
incendios del 2019
y estoy muy preocupado porque si se
quema en los próximos días no tendré
donde vivir
son cinco los puntos de concentración de
las llamas el foco que más amenaza a la
población es el de santa cruz en el
centro de california la zona vio
devastados por las llamas al menos 50
hogares solo estoy tratando de hacer
algunos contra fuegos hacemos lo que
podemos pero con este viento los fuegos
se disparan todo esto podría ser en vano
podría ser un ejercicio inútil porque ya
sabes todo lo que se necesita es una
chispa
quiero decir esa casa no se estaba
quemando hace media hora esto tampoco
las fuerzas ráfagas de vientos sumadas a
la importante ola de calor no ayudan a
los bomberos del estado
la semana pasada california registraba
un nuevo récord mundial de temperatura
en 54,4 grados otra consecuencia de los
incendios que preocupa a los expertos de
salud es la degradación de la calidad
del aire en plena pandemia de
coronavirus el humo podría volverse un
peligro más especialmente para los
mayores o los que padecen enfermedades
respiratorias la casa blanca anunció que
se opone a un proyecto de ley demócrata
que busca darle ayuda económica de
emergencia al servicio postal este
plantea un paquete de 25.000 millones de
dólares para el servicio de correos el
presidente donald trump sigue asegurando
que el voto por éste por correo es el
vehículo para el fraude en las
elecciones de noviembre hoy el director
del servicio postal viste yo hoy
testificó ante miembros del congreso y
aseguró que planea cambios para el
servicio postal pero que éstos no serán
implementados hasta después de los
comicios de noviembre presidente trump
hizo referencia a la convención
demócrata y volvió a expresar sus dudas
sobre la validez de los resultados de
las elecciones
los demócratas celebraron la convención
más oscura enojada y pesimista de la
historia del país pasaron cuatro días
seguidos atacando a estados unidos como
un país racista y horrible que necesita
redención spirit game show bai ling
replay
joe biden declaró una temporada de
oscuridad y vean lo que hemos logrado
hasta que llegó la plaga miren lo que
hemos logrado y lo haremos nuevamente
para poder saber cuál es el resultado de
esta elección
en mi opinión durante semanas o meses
tal vez nunca tal vez años pero tal vez
nunca maybe sprint y maybe never los dos
gobiernos rivales de libia anunciara un
alto el fuego inmediato en un gesto para
frenar la violencia y queda una
esperanza una posible paz estable luego
de seis años de guerra civil en el país
desde la onu han acogido con
satisfacción el avance y el presidente
egipcio celebró este paso hasta hasta la
estabilidad de la zona
es un movimiento que podría significar
una nueva era en libia en declaraciones
separadas el presidente fayed al sarraj
jefe del gobierno de trípoli reconocido
por la onu y águila sale portavoz del
parlamento del gobierno con sede en
bengasi aliado con el mariscal jalifa
haftar declararon un alto el fuego
inmediato la misión de la onu en libia
aseguró que los anuncios demostraron el
coraje que libia necesitaba urgentemente
y pidió a las partes que estén a la
altura de esta decisión histórica ambos
gobiernos han estado en guerra
prácticamente desde la formación del
gobierno de acuerdo nacional de trípoli
en diciembre de 2015 las fuerzas de
captar comenzaron a expandirse por el
estudio del sur del país y lanzaron una
feroz ofensiva para capturar trípoli
capital del país pero en junio de 2020
tuvieron que retirarse después de que el
gobierno de al sarraj recibiese la ayuda
militar de turquía en julio el
parlamento de egipto aliado de las
fuerzas de haftar aprobó el despliegue
de tropas alrededor del último campo de
batalla la ciudad de sirte algo que
aumentó el miedo a una guerra indirecta
entre ankara y el cairo en 'twitter' el
presidente egipcio
el alto el fuego acojo con beneplácito
las declaraciones emitidas por el
consejo presidencial y la cámara de
representantes de libia de cesar el
fuego y detener las operaciones
militares en todas las tierras libias ya
que este es un paso importante en el
camino hacia el logro de un arreglo
político las dos partes también
acordaron celebrar elecciones en un
futuro la situación sigue siendo
precaria en sirte la puerta de entrada a
las instalaciones petroleras de libia
aunque al sarraj pidió crear zonas
desmilitarizadas en la ciudad costera
saleh propuso instaurar un gobierno
nuevo en la zona
hasta aquí la informativa en francés de
cuadro continué con nosotros buena noche
[Música]